le soldat allemand est littéralement au
bout de son rouleau
il vient de il vient de daval et 800 km
à pied la plupart du temps en combattant
il a remporté les plus fabuleuses
victoire de la seconde guerre mondiale
il a fait une campagne pratiquement sans
faute mais il n'en peut plus cette arme
est encore une fois c'est un fantôme et
coop mais comme on projette que l'armée
rouge est encore empirer tas on pense
que il suffit de donner un dernier coup
des pôles
en réalité nous le savons aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les allemands ne pouvait pas prendre
moscou c'était pas possible au moment où
ils ont voulu le prendre au moment où
ils ont voulu prendre parce que le
staline a fermé les réserves ya trois
armes et de réserve toute neuve qui sont
planqués dans les forêts qui attendent
c'est geof qui a pris en main la la
défense ils voient bien que de l'autre
côté salé le le le système militaire est
en train de tomber en morceaux
littéralement tout tout ce qui lui
revient le 30 novembre est là dès le 1er
décembre le 30 novembre déjà parus
téléphone à staline en dix ans bah c'est
maintenant c'est maintenant qu'il faut
me donner les trois adresses des trois
armées de réserve parce que c'est
maintenant qu'on peut les battre mais
j'irai encore plus loin même si par
miracle il avait réussi à prendre moscou
quoi qu'est ce qui aurait été gagné
est-ce que l'union soviétique et l'armée
rouge aurait cessé de lutter
certainement pas certainement pas ah
bien sûr ça aura été moralement un coup
très dur mais d'une part je ne suis pas
du tout persuadé que les allemands mais
les forces pour garder moscou déjà parce
que prendre moscou ça voulait dire soit
faire un siège comme à leningrad
mais ils n'ont pas assez de forces pour
encercler quand même cette ville qui est
deux fois et demi plus grande que
leningrad ou ça veut dire s'engager dans
une guerre urbaine dont on a vu un
stalingrad que c'est pas le truc de
l'armée allemande lé pas bâti pour ça
donc encore une fois même s'ils jouent
comme avait laissé avancer les allemands
jusque dans la capitale
il fallait la prendre une fois une fois
prises il fallait la tenir et même en
admettant qu'elles aient été prises et
tenu encore une fois ça ne probablement
ça ne provoquait pas la chute
du régime stalinien
[Musique]